مراسل سي إن إن البشير موجود في بيروت في مكان
الهجوم المميت، وما مدى
أهمية العاروري
داخل
حماس، حسنًا، انظر، نحن نتحدث عن الرجل
الثاني حقًا في
المكتب السياسي لحماس كما ذكرت هناك،
فهو يعتبر واحدًا من  مؤسسو
كتائب ألاسان، الجناح العسكري لحركة
حماس، يعد هذا تصعيدًا كبيرًا،
وكما ترون ورائي، فقد تجمعت حشود
من وسائل الإعلام، وهذا
تطور مهم، وهناك مخاوف بشأن كيفية
انتشار هذا الأمر إلى ما هو أبعد من ذلك بالطبع،
هذا أمر غير مسبوق إلى حد ما  شاهد
هذا النوع من الهجمات داخل بيروت،
تذكر أن هذه هي العاصمة وليس
جنوب لبنان حيث نميل إلى رؤية
هذه المناوشات بين إسرائيل ولبنان
التي سمعناها من وكالة الأنباء الوطنية اللبنانية التي أفادت
أنهم يقولون إن ثلاثة انفجارات
تصف هذا  كضربة جوية
وكنا نسمع أه من
السكان المحليين لقد تحدثنا إلى
أصحاب المتاجر على بعد بضعة أبواب هنا الذين
وصفوا سماع ثلاثة انفجارات مدوية
أه عندما وقع الحادث الآن
بالطبع كما ذكرت لم
تعلن إسرائيل مسؤوليتها  فيما يتعلق بالحادث،
تواصلنا في الواقع مع
الجيش الإسرائيلي، لكنهم رفضوا التعليق،
وسمعنا قبل ذلك بقليل من مارك جرير،
كبير مستشاري رئيس الوزراء
بنيامين نتنياهو، قال إن إسرائيل
لم تعلن مسؤوليتها ولكن من الواضح أن
من نفذ هذا الهجوم
لم يكن كذلك.  استهداف الدولة اللبنانية
ليس استهداف الله بشكل حاسم ولكن كما
ترون خلفي أعني الداي
هنا منتشر على الأقل 100
متر حوله ولكن إذا نظرتم إلى
أه موقع الانفجار فمن الواضح أنه
دقيق جداً
مستهدف جداً هو إسرائيل  يستعدون بالفعل
للانتقام مع الأخذ في الاعتبار أن حزب الله
تعهد بأنه سيرد إذا
نفذت إسرائيل أي أه من هذا القبيل
في
لبنان، حسنًا، انظر إلى قلق جبل الإسكان
منذ أسابيع الآن بشأن
التصعيد الذي يمكن أن نرى فيه
انتقامًا محتملاً عبر الحدود، وهو أمر مهم
للتأكيد على أننا نتحدث عنه
مسؤول كبير في حماس هنا ولكن كما
ذكرت الحسا كان واضحا أن أي
هجوم على الأراضي اللبنانية من شأنه،
وفقا لمسؤولي الحسبة، أن يؤدي إلى
رد فعل عنيف على الأراضي اللبنانية. من
المهم الآن أن نعرف أن هذا يأتي في
سياق بناء التوترات على
الحدود التي رأيناها مع إسرائيل.  تنفيذ
غارات جوية على القرى اللبنانية في تلك
المنطقة الحدودية الجنوبية أه رأينا
مدنيين يقتلون وكذلك صحفيين
كانوا ينقلون أن الحسبة
بدورها تستهدف
المواقع الإسرائيلية في جميع المجالات وبالطبع
نتوقع أن نسمع من رئيس
سوف يراقب hbor Hasan N All Eyes
لمعرفة ما سيقوله حول
هذا الحادث الأخير